I'm literally moving into college today
and soon it'll be moving out day a
source tells ET that lower T lock leads
daughter's Olivia and Bella are having a
tough time dealing with the domino
effect of the college admissions bribery
scandal that their parents are allegedly
involved in both Lori and her husband
Massimo were among the 50 people charged
in the scam now a source tells e t quote
Bella and Olivia are suffering in their
own ways from the fallout of their
parents decisions court documents allege
that the couple paid bribes totaling
five hundred thousand dollars to have
their kids designated as recruits to the
University of Southern California crew
team even though they never actually
participated in the sport she's accused
of conspiring with this guy in
California paid him a half a million
dollars to get her two daughters into
college so they got into college under
false pretenses the source says Bella
and Olivia have a very tight-knit group
of friends who have been there to
support them they've needed that support
because they're being attacked at every
turn the source adds that of the two
girls 20 year old Bella was quote far
more invested in college and would love
to have completed USC I'm also literally
never at school that I think my class
doesn't even and maybe they forget I go
there meanwhile olivia is quote so
embarrassed she doesn't even want to go
out I do want the experience of like
gamedays partying I don't really care
about school as you guys know the source
says the 19 year old youtuber is quote
really angry with her parents because
she told them she did not want to go to
college and she was pushed adding now
she's devastated because everything she
built imploded before her eyes she feels
they ruined everything I want them to be
happy so I want to be supportive of
everything they want to do but I do want
them to have somewhat of a normal you
know finish out of high school college
experience maybe because I didn't have
that I would I really want that for them
since news of the scandal broke two of
Olivia's major sponsors Tresemme and
Sephora dropped the teenager
and earlier this week USC announced that
they are preventing any students
associated with the scandal from
registering for classes while their
cases are under review following the
review the college said that it will
take the proper action related to their
status up to revoking admission or
expulsion a source previously told et
that the sisters are quote afraid of
being kicked out of school and will
likely not return on their own
Lauria Mossimo are currently each out of
jail on a 1 million dollar bond their
next court appearance will be later this
month in Boston it is a felony so they
could face jail or prison time however I
would expect that they would probably
just face a hefty fine if they were
convicted